spring signifies renewal so it is the
perfect time to get a jump start on your
spring cleaning by refreshing and
revitalizing your entire home with the
dream team of clean zero res and joining
me today is ben mckee one of the owners
and operators of xero res las vegas no
one cleans like zero res and we're so
glad to have you guys back with us today
tell us why xerorez is so different than
the other guys you know you gotta look
at the carpet cleaning industry it
hasn't changed in nearly 80 years
they're still using soaps they're still
using surfactants and this stuff has no
business being in your carpet or on your
floors at your house it causes you know
your carpets to dry crunchy causes the
resoil fast we don't use any toxic
chemicals as your res no soaps none of
that you have clean carpets that last a
whole lot longer and you just use water
which a lot of people think how can you
clean with just water well this isn't
just any water no it's a special it's a
patented process that we have we're
utilizing alkaline water and that's how
we get away without using the soaps and
harsh chemicals the cleaning results are
phenomenal you can see what we're able
to do in people's homes on the screen
and the best part is mercedes is it
dries really fast in fact it's up to 200
faster dry time than our leading
competitor i've had you in my home so
many times and just recently you guys
were there and it was so amazing that
you came i'd say at like 10 o'clock in
the morning by 4 o'clock in the
afternoon everything was completely dry
we were walking on our carpet which i
love because i hate waiting for it to
dry that is the worst part about it
right absolutely absolutely and cleaning
also reduces the airborne contaminants
in your home or at your business by up
to 52
there's a study out there and they've
actually found that you could reduce
like fungi by 61 percent just by getting
your carpets professionally cleaned so
with zero register you're in really good
hands it's going to be healthy and
hygienic yeah a lot of times we worry
about what it is that we see but
sometimes you have to worry about what
you don't see and that's the thing look
at this carpet this is
a lot of what you see when you go into
people's homes and zerorez is able to
get these disgusting
like traffic patterns taken out pet
stays taken out with it just one swoop
and it's because of your empowered water
can we yeah let's put it to the test a
little test here i mean
like you said
we see carpets like this day in and day
out so if your carpet looks like this at
home or at work don't worry we got your
back and i am amazed every time we clean
we just get amazing clean lines this is
just our zero water
process no soaps we didn't put any
chemicals on here
these are this is one
two three four swipes and already the
difference is
amazing
it is it's incredible let's talk a
little bit about your customer service
because it's second to none the people
that work at zerorez are fantastic it is
we've won best of las vegas three years
in a row uh with the gold rating it's
amazing and it's because we're out there
we're treating every customer like
they're part of the family you know
we're we're a family-run business our
technicians are a call center they're a
part of our family as well so when you
call us you're getting treated basically
uh by the family you really are the best
you got to give xerorez a call their
number is
702-840-3333 you can also visit them
online at
xerorezlasvegas.com and make sure you
take advantage of their spring cleaning
special you can get your carpets cleaned
for as low as 35 dollars per room plus
receive free tile cleaning of up to 100
square feet minimum supply
we'll be right back